this morning the FBI is looking into the
death of a black man after he was
stopped by police in Minneapolis the
attempted arrest was caught on camera
and we need to warn you here that it's
very difficult to watch the video of
last night's confrontation shows a white
police officer with his knee pinning
down the neck of the suspect and you can
clearly hear the man saying I can't
breathe several times before an
ambulance arrives Jeff Pegues is
following this story for us Jeff what
are police doing about this
Hale good morning both of the officers
involved in this incident are on paid
administrative leave this morning
pending the results of the investigation
police were responding to a report of a
forgery they say the suspect appeared to
be under the influence and resisted
arrest before suffering what they call
medical distress we want to warn you
what happened after that is difficult to
watch this 10-minute video posted to
Facebook overnight shows Minneapolis
police officers holding down a man one
officer uses his knee to pin the man's
neck down and breathe several times
during the arrest the man tells officers
that he's struggling to breathe and begs
for some relief
some people who gathered at the scene
try to help Japanese breathing right
there bro
but his officers work to keep onlookers
back the man on the ground appears to
move less and less five minutes into the
video the man seems to be motionless and
the police officers knee is still on his
neck he's not you moved here seven
minutes into the video an ambulance
arrives when an EMT does the first pulse
check officers still have the man pinned
and when he's loaded onto the ambulance
his hands are still cuffed police
explained what led up to the incident in
an overnight news conference after he
got out he physically resisted officers
officers were able to get the suspect
into handcuffs and officers noticed that
the male was going into medical distress
officers called for an ambulance he was
transported to Hennepin County Medical
Center where he died a short time later
he said not identified the man and they
say the officers body cameras were on
and activated during that incident this
is reminiscent of Eric Garner's very
same words I can breathe uh turd as he
was dying on the streets of Staten
Island New York in 2014 that phrase
became a rallying cry for millions
nationwide in a plea to end police
brutality
Gail Jeff that video is so disturbing to
watch we know how the Eric garner case
turned out and you said he was stopped
for forgery is that what you said in the
beginning yeah that's right
it wasn't an incident where he was armed
police say that he was stopped for
forgery obviously there will be an
investigation
I hope so that video raises a lot of
very disturbing questions and what we
heard from the police officers so far
does not seem to be very satisfying
thank you very much Jeff thank you is
the right word there